[Música]
então voltaram a contar a todos é
obrigado pelo é pela nossa cozinha
santos mais agradecer também o convite é
passarmos de uma maneira presentes que
estão neste momento em que se fala é
intensa no qual é o nosso papel não é
meu eu trabalho na área o novo visual já
há cerca de seis anos é e em tóquio nos
dias que correm
este ano sendo qual é o melhor caminho a
seguir uma vez que os nossos os nossos
interlocutores rápida pouco falava e vai
é dos desafios que hoje em dia é existem
é nesta nesta inspirado nós criamos
impacto emocional junto às pessoas tanto
é que o que se passa na rádio passa está
na encontro visão porque porque é uma
procura é constante no mundo que está
permanentemente vai mudar sabíamos dessa
semana é uma história muito rica nesse
aspecto é com essa meta é borbulhar que
o masters incentivo é que ela procura
que que existem todas aquelas pessoas
demais melhor nas tecnologias coisas
para melhorarem a qualidade de vida das
pessoas e e esta é este o desafio que
nós temos permanentemente em mãos
é verdade que nós temos uma situação é é
que eu a publicidade está está neste
momento a mudar e nós nem a supervisão
de sempre é quem está é perceber como é
que esta tendência está está está a
caminhar tanto desde 2007 que nós
fazemos as telenovelas pra classe que ia
ser o fp é verdade é que todos os anos
sendo cada vez que foi aos mercados
internacionais vai a canon o nome para o
miptv ser cada vez mais a tendência
mundial e uma mudança constante não sabe
qual é o caminho para a gente diz que o
caminhão digital
mas onde está o negócio é isto faz-nos
pensar todo o paradigma é todo meu
negócio que está estruturado sobre o
estado neste sábado sobre o mundo sobre
a publicidade facto os conteúdos têm que
criar
é mais impacto no final pra quem está
chegando ao fim esse caso contrário nós
estamos fazendo bons jogos por acaso na
tanto de algum tempo a esta parte que o
mundo devia falar que tenho tido muitas
mudanças e essas mudanças nós assistimos
de alimentos à imprensa o investimento
publicitário no mercado aqui em 76 por
cento
agora pra casa este ano temos boas
notícias outros
nos anos em que o mercado caiu 19%
tudo isso é um caminho nesse contexto de
catástrofe pista e peças muitas vezes
também que a comissão vai acabar e que
nada disso vai vai vai continuar a muito
muito muito audiência caminha focava
toque com base nisto fato nós nos
desafiamos diariamente para para
continuar a contar boas boas histórias e
é isso que nos faz pensar de que forma
podemos continuar a fazê-lo e mantendo
naturalmente comprou o hotel ver de
sucesso que ter que tentar um temos
temos tido aqui modalidade que o que eu
diga em tom de brincadeira e que nós
chamamos o amor apenas na época hoje em
dia nada disto ea linear é cada vez mais
comentou embaixo que a experiência de
visualização dos conteúdos que onde come
enquanto no fundo e esta alteração do
paradigma negócio publicitário que nós
sugerimos gerimos o que queremos ver em
vez do que aqui até no fundo já está
completamente aculturar nosso de ouvida
e é isso tem de facto está a mudar é que
o cabeça 15 anos acontecia é improvisam
as audiências no parlamento que é é o
nosso baluarte nosso museu partir do
qual nós temos que trabalhar ea verdade
é que até então até à data atirando
respirando futebol os tipos festivais de
verão e as corridas
agora todos os filhos mas não existem
ainda existe aqui um é verdade é que as
novelas são ainda hoje um agregador de
alguém assinar e e as marcas que estarão
todas as pessoas no fundo ainda
continuamos a ter 11 11
é estressante de retenção de
investimento todo diariamente não há
nenhum conteúdo que contacta com tantas
pessoas tanto futebol contacto mas só
com uma diária e é semanal e neste
aspecto tropa de choque para administrar
é essa em 800 pessoas um milhão e
trezentas mil pessoas que o fato
na teoria é assistir a uma novela nossa
tá este facto tem valor e têm valor e
tem um valor enorme terreno cultural e é
com base nisso que nós tínhamos que
pensar a manteiga e continuar essa ser
bom e barato
em portugal não há outra forma de fazer
diferente o foco agora hoje em dia
a nossa principal preocupação olha minha
principal preocupação olha que a
operação da empresa e no fundo como é
que nós podemos sim ser um mercado que
como altamente competitivo
hoje entramos em casa pelo carro toda
uma variedade de séries prêmio é sem
qualquer tipo de canais que permitem a
portugal assim com qualquer tipo de
responsabilidade produção no causa não
tem nenhum compromisso de produzir
localmente nada é tanto um canal também
competir com alterações do comportamento
dos consumidores
os nossos solos apenas que nós hoje em
dia passamos e passamos conteúdos
orçamentos cada vez mais a diminuir
desafios aumentar no fundo e é grande a
grande dificuldade hoje em dia da área
audiovisual que é uma questão que requer
uma atenção muito postar diária e não ao
museu não há não há uma métrica não há
nada com esse objetivo em mente possa
seguir não é um avião e também é claro
que não se identificando melhor qual é o
melhor mesmo é votar até à data
nós temos o nosso segredo é certo que
temos aqui um é uma caixinha eu sou lá
em 40 existem limpeza para ingredientes
que nós ou três anos temos tido sucesso
nós dizemos que o som da turma que quer
ela é a alma do negócio
mas será que é mesmo tudo será que não
há aqui mais nada daqui até à data posso
dizer com segurança que
é nós temos feito da seguinte forma nós
temos tido sempre a preocupação de ter
conteúdos em que de alguma maneira seja
imaginativos neto dentro de um padrão um
paradigma de um negócio que não se pode
afastar muito mais porque o cliente que
é isso fundar um time que são fatos à
medida
nós temos que ter imaginação naquilo que
possa apresentar e falar temos a
preocupação de criar no fim da vida de
bravata mateus que falava pequenina
rádio e aquilo que se passa a ter neve
objectivamente na provisão a nossa em
dia temos que tinha explicar assuntos do
cotidiano porque as histórias que nós
queremos contar suas histórias de vida
das pessoas é isso tem impacto no final
não só um temas que não não existe
nenhuma relação específica jogo nosso
público é um pouco criaria mente
contacto em 800 mil pessoas que
diariamente ainda se predispõe a sentar
à frente o professor e ver e conta com
esta é com esse conteúdo é aí que está é
aí que está o nosso negócio aí que está
a nossa a nossa força tanto ter
imaginação para detetar e porque a
atenção dessas pessoas pois é retirar
aquela acel lâmpada é que nos diz que
mais do que uma história que fazer o
tempo trazendo para quem a que se
destina à questão qual é o público o
nosso alvo e naturalmente cria no total
o impacto emocional pois falava e ao
invés do guião estranhos não diz que o
atentado às torres de falar nisso porque
já tinham experiências em que não
conseguiu tal como como nós queríamos e
as coisas foram com ele e também foi um
desastre nuclear ou no câmbio depois
adaptamos à realidade
hoje em dia que quer contar com
políticos nós já não é o mesmo de ontem
que introduzir nas nossas histórias
novas temáticas treinar duas
preocupações para reter a atenção diz
público o núcleo juvenil tem uma
importância enorme algum núcleo cômico
tá tudo isso as piadas aquelas pedrinhas
símbolo de que possível vou contar mas
nas escolas e isso é fundamental para
criar a empresa se e gerar e gerir teerã
a audiência
tatu um conteúdo que possa viver
realismo incorporar os temas fraturantes
lutar histórias me absurdo se nessa
estatística no fundo um pouquinho mais
contra um time emocionalmente com o
consumidor
estou depois ao nosso lado o homem
elástico que tal flexibilidade ea
capacidade da nossa história também dar
aqui uma presença do cotidiano da vida a
vida de todas as boas práticas mensagens
e hoje única que vai expulsar a ter
muita empresa não tanto das marcas que
já estão presentes nas nossas nossa
história mas somente boas práticas o que
a inglaterra se fala muito ruim do time
que é integrar mesma situação da da
sessão porque sou alzheimer
ontem uma personagem que tem que ceder
dificuldade do santa tudo isto só tem 13
que dorme para somente comunicar nada
mais do que isso
depois te ter aqui um acto maior
criatura colaborativa que eu acho que é
fundamental é tudo isto que se junta num
só motora e que trabalha perto do fim e
aí que eu acho que está é grande é
grande força da função da espn o sucesso
em sucesso das novelas ter uma coisa
muito objetiva saber toda a gente
trabalhar com uma determinada uma
guinada meta e se assim a falhar é um
problema poderia ser tem que ficar onde
viu que o que aconteceu aqui ou na
teoria se encontram se várias histórias
centradas aqui um é uma história curiosa
que há uns anos atrás ainda uma outra
empresa estava a gravar em servir como é
uma série e isso é uma equipa alargada
em que numa primeira fase os custos de
produção querem correr sem sangue eram
enviados para parar no ponto e só pôde
chegar à rua portugal
nesta primeira fase a equipe estava tal
maneira focada nessa nessa altura tive
essas métricas que tenham
obrigatoriamente cumprir chega a
portugal um uma despesa que não tenha
documento para justificar tanto na
altura não vim aqui o proforma todo o
ano fiscal e não sabe que não existe
isso
então uma despesa
ficar sozinho eu sinto que era um valor
que já não quatro como quanto era e que
falava não tinha é macaco
usei homem a nota ficou tocando que ele
e eu próprio também não vive só de
pensar que o nosso não quer saber
naturalmente não fica tudo aquilo que
lhe é achar estranho
depois vamos tentar saber o que tinha
por que tinha acontecido e foi uma coisa
muito simples
no fundo era o drive estava conduzindo
um conjunto de atores teve um furo e
pokémon fui assim e tal maneira ficava
que tenha que estudar os atores ponto na
de corte não era dele um par de óculos o
que o fez e vai como afirma kahn pegou
um conjunto de pessoas que estavam ali à
volta do natal carro mudou o leão me
segure a sites do fundo só mostrou o
quão importante é que os presentes que a
meta é que ele tem que ser rigorosamente
cumpridas por não existe espaço na nova
para fazer o flamengo enfrenta o avaí
que ficar essa história do dakar sozinho
no carro sai usei o homem tanto que
parei com nós temos então imaginação ao
tomarmos estas parcelas a imaginação e
criatividade virá a flexibilidade a esta
é a quinta turma colaborativa
nós chegamos a algo muito muito muito
suscetíveis ao muito positivo para nós é
este torneio feedback joana e e falavam
visão
eu acho que é isso não tenho certeza que
é isso que dá força à as histórias e os
conteúdos
este impacto emocional e gq histórias
criam junto das pessoas porque são
histórias vindas de alguma maneira a
história que nós contamos hoje tem
alguma coisa diretamente com elas
conhecem alguém que já tenha uma
situação idêntica e nós temos as nossas
histórias no coração das pessoas como se
elas tivessem houvesse style que está
nessa situação
não foi uma personagem que terão o chefe
da 8ª para rodas
isto cria cria vulgo explicação as duas
ficam ao terminar as corridas e
falta identificar por servir este
estiver histórias têm geram esta é a
extinção não medirem excluindo forte
muito forte é absolutamente emocionante
obrigado a isso quando foi a integração
da seleção portuguesa dos anos em que há
36 franco desempenhava uma personagem
que se arrependa começa a sofrer desta
doença
depois temos um corpo mais duas dois
exemplos que momentos que mundialmente
que marcam comportamentos fizeram uma
coisa tão simples como é a ser apontado
ver conteúdo fazia como é numa novela em
que junto do mar um público mais juvenil
cria comunicar que são das cores que
sabia fazer é ficar agendas dos produtos
e tudo acontece uma forma criativa e
emocional
por exemplo no núcleo cômico mas a gata
é este este fluxo de comunicação onde se
vai buscar as boas ideias porque a
história som estava sob saias a história
acontece em portugal como acontecem nos
estados unidos a verdade é que depois
nesse papel de embrulho existem
situações muito particulares que diz
respeito a nós e é isto que está em
atenção
no fundo é isto que não é mais do que a
criação da tal rfa né e situava o que
nos faz todos os dias a chegar a casa e
ter um público daquele exemplo o estrago
do milhão e trezentas mil pessoas sentam
à feira com visão e que ainda conta com
os frutos que reaja a isso facto um
valor muito importante pra nós que no
fundo o que tá por trás deste sucesso é
alma a alma do que fazemos não é mais do
que ganhou em emoção titular não é
trazer emoções para nossa vida
e quanto mais as emoções mas essa
história com que que esse sentido de
pertença né que nós temos dos nossos
conteúdos quanto mais estiver visível
quanto mais isso formaria quanto mais
forte for esta presença das nossas
histórias mais forte elas tornam e é
aqui que zidane claramente a força é a
força do nosso o nosso conteúdo
assim enquanto falava pouco que o
estaleiro é a alma do negócio e que
naquela caixinha
nós temos alguém que os ingredientes
é fico aqui pública da área ou não nós
dizemos sempre que você vê trauma do
negócio mas demos mais que a alma é que
é o segredo do negócio
e é verdade porque devia acho que nós
desempenhamos mais é integrar as
histórias crise em espanha histórias e
momentos da vida das pessoas e das
nossas nossas novelas e nas nossas
férias da nossa ficção claramente o
produto sem ganhar e é isso que eu acho
que também pode ser adotado tanto na
área da ficção
neste caso concreto como em qualquer
tipo de negócio e é aqui que tudo aquilo
que nós empregamos todos os ingredientes
que fazem de fato o produto final ser
outro tem outro corpo tem outra outra
presença e tem que o impacto emocional
muito muito maior a cair seu
[Aplausos]
[Música]